hi everyone my name is ishai and i would
like to tell you about the complexity of
finding fair independence sets in cycles
our story starts in 1986 when dussu and
wang have studied the cycle plus
triangles problem in this problem
we are given a graph g on three times n
vertices
whose set of edges is the disjoint union
of a hamilton cycle
and n vertex disjoint triangles consider
for example the cycle on 15 vertices in
the figure
and suppose that the three yellow
vertices form a triangle in the graph
and that the red vertices form another
triangle in the graph
and so on every column corresponds to a
triangle in our graph
dussu and wang asked whether such a
graph must contain
an independent set of size n or
equivalently
if one can choose one vertex from each
triangle
to obtain a set of n vertices with no
two consecutive
vertices along the cycle the conjecture
that the answer is positive
and as you can see in the figure the
five highlighted vertices
form an independent set in the cycle and
it includes one vertex from every column
when eddie shared about this question he
proposed a stronger conjecture
saying that such a graph is in fact
recolorable
meaning that the vertex set can be
partitioned into three
independent sets of size n looking again
at our example you can see that the
graph has another independent set of
size
five and there is another one so this
graph is indeed three colorable
both the conjectures of dussu and wang
grind of erdesh
were confirmed by flashing hdbits in
1992.
in fact they proved the conjecture in a
stronger form with respect to the least
coloring variant of the problem
the proof used an algebraic approach of
a learning currency based on polynomials
and an alternative proof for the three
colorability result was then given by
stacks
these proofs however are not constructed
in the sense that they do not supply an
efficient algorithm with polynomial
running time
that given a graph on three n vertices
with sort of edges
is the disjoint union of a hamilton
cycle and n
vertex disjoint triangles finds its
recalling of the graph or at least an
independent set of size
n questions about the computational
aspects of the cycle plus triangles
problem
were asked by several researchers over
the years but no hardness result is
currently known
for the problem a natural generalization
of the cycle plus triangles problem is
that of fair independence sets in cycles
let g be a cycle graph and let v1 up to
vm
be a partition of its vertex set into m
sets as example consider this cycle
and let the yellow vertices be the
vertices of the first part of
v1 let the red vertices be the ones of
v2
and so on we are interested in an
independent set of the
cycle that includes roughly half of the
vertices of every part vi
of the given partition more precisely we
say that an
independent set s of the cycle g fairly
represents the partition
if for every i from 1 to m the number of
vertices of
s that belong to v i is at least half
the size
of v i minus 1.
notice that if each of the sets v 1 up
to vm
is of size t then the question here is
closely related to the cycle plus
triangles problem
in the graph from the figure you can see
that the highlighted vertices form an
independent set that further represents
the partition
for example we have here five red
vertices
and our independent set includes two of
them just as required
in a work of argonia alone berger
chudnovsky kotler level
and there it was shown that for every
cycle
and for every partition of its vertex
set there exists an independent set that
fairly represents the partition
in a later work of alishai and munir it
was shown that if the number of vertices
and the number m of parts of the
partition have the same parity
then not only that there exists an
independent set that failure represents
the partition
but there are even two disjoint such
independent sets
that together cover all the vertices of
the cycle
but one from each part vi
so let's highlight in the figure another
independent set that further represents
the partition
and notice that together with the
previous one they miss only one vertex
from each
color it's interesting to mention that
although the statements of these results
are purely combinatorial
their proofs are based on tools from
topology the first application of
topology in combinatorics was obtained
in 1979 by lovas
who proved that the chromatic number of
the knesset graph with parameters n and
k
is n minus 2 k plus 2. the knesser graph
denoted here by
k of n and k is the graph whose vertices
are all the
k subsets of the integers from one to n
where two such sets are adjacent in the
graph if they are disjoint
lovas used the burst coulomb theorem
from algebraic topology
to precisely determine the chromatic
number of this graph
this result was extended and generalized
in various ways
and one such extension was obtained by
scriber
who studied the subgraph of the knesset
graph k of n and k
induced by the collection of all k
subsets of the integers from 1 to n
with no two consecutive integers modulo
n
it proved again by a topological
argument
that this subgraph has the same
chromatic number of n
minus two k plus two and this subgraph
is commonly referred to as describe a
graph
it is denoted here by s of n and k
the proof of our only at r for the
existence of an independent set that
failure presents any given partition of
the vertex set of a cycle
uses the chromatic number of described
graph
whereas the proof of alicia in munium is
based on what is known as the octahedral
lemma
that can be viewed as a combinatorial
formulation of the borsu coolant theorem
that was applied by matushek
in an alternative roof for the chromatic
number of knesset graphs
since these proofs are based on tools
from topology it is perhaps not
surprising
that they only guarantee the existence
of an independent set
that failure represents the partition
but they do not suggest an efficient
algorithm
for the search problem of finding such
an independent set
given a cycle and departation of each
vertex set
the goal of the current work is to
understand the computational complexity
of such problems
so before presenting the results let me
briefly introduce some complexity
classes of total search problems
the complexity class tfmp was defined by
megiddo and papa dimitrivio in 1991
as the class of all the total search
problems those
problems for which every input is
guaranteed to have a solution
where the solutions can be verified in
polynomial running time
in 1994 papa dimitri initiated the study
of total search problems
in view of the mathematical argument
that lies at the existence proof of
their solutions
it defines several complexity classes
subclasses of tfmp
each of which corresponds to a certain
mathematical argument
one such complexity class is ppa
polynomial parity argument
this class corresponds to the simple
fact that in every undirected graph with
maximum degree 2
that has a vertex of degree 1 there
exists another
vertex of degree 1. so ppa is defined as
the class of all
problems that can be efficiently reduced
to a canonical problem called
leaf in which given a circuit that
represents a graph with maximum degree 2
and given a vertex of degree 1 the goal
is to find another such vectors
another class defined in this way is
ppad
which is a subclass of ppa that can be
viewed as the analog of ppa for directed
graphs
ppid is defined using a canonical
problem known as
end offline and the class ppid is known
to perfectly capture the complexity
of several important search problems of
interest
already in property meet views paper it
will show that the search problem
associated with sperno's lemma
is ppad complete and over the years ppid
completeness was proved for several
other problems such as the one
associated with the nash equilibrium
theorem
for ppa however until a few years ago
no natural ppa complete problems were
known
whereby naturally mean that the problems
don't involve
circuits and turing machines in their
definitions
the situation was changed following
recent results of philosophers and
goldberg
who proved the ppa completeness of a
problem called
consensus halving and they used it to
derive the ppa completeness of
additional classical problems
like the problem of splitting necklaces
with two seeds and
cutting discreet sandwiches in the
current work we contribute a few
additional problems to the list of ppa
complete natural problems
and now we are ready to present the
results
we start by introducing the problem
called fair independent setting cycle
in this problem we are given as input a
cycle g
and the partition v 1 up to v m of its
vector set
and the goal is to find an independent
set of g that fairly represents the
partition
as mentioned earlier the existence of a
solution to every input
is guaranteed by a result of harmonies
out
and here we show that the problem is ppa
complete
we next consider the first splitting
cycle problem
of finding two disjoint independent sets
of a cycle
that fairly represent a given partition
and cover together
all vertices but one from each part vi
in fact we consider here an approximate
version of the problem with parameter
epsilon
where the two disjoint independent sets
s1 and
s2 are required to include at least half
minus epsilon fraction of the vertices
of each vi
here the existence of a solution is
guaranteed by the result of alicia
and muni already for the exact version
of the problem with epsilon equals
and this exact version is shown here to
be ppa complete
we further show that the problem is
unlikely to have a polynomial
time algorithm even for a certain
constant positive epsilon
because for such an epsilon the problem
is shown to be p p
b hard we finally consider a problem
that corresponds to
colorings of square graphs in describer
problem
we are given as input a circuit that
represents a coloring of the vertices of
the squirrel graph
s of n and k using n minus two k
plus one color recall that
this is smaller by one than the
chromatic number of the graph which is
n minus two k plus two so such a
coloring must have two adjacent vertices
with the same color
and our goal in this problem is to find
the monochromatic
edge using the connection discovered by
aronia tal
between fair independence sets in cycles
and the chromatic number of squabble
graphs
we derive the ppa completeness of this
problem as well
the proofs of the results are based on a
chain of reductions
our starting point is the consensus
halving problem which was proved to be
ppart by philosophers and goalbelt
we showed that this problem is
efficiently reducible to the firm
independent set in cycle problem
which is reduced to both their first
splitting cycle problem
and describer problem these two problems
can be reduced to a problem associated
with the octahedral lemma
which is known to lie in ppa essentially
already from the original work of
papadimitriou
this is how we get the ppa completeness
of the three problems
i would like to briefly describe now the
high level idea of the main reduction
so for simplicity of presentation let's
focus on a direct reduction from the
consensus halving problem
to the exact version of the first
splitting cycle problem
the consensus solving problem with
parameter epsilon is defined as follows
we are given empowerability measures
denoted by mu1
upto mum defined on the interval from 0
to 1.
it can be assumed that the probability
measures are given by their piecewise
constant density functions
and our goal is to partition the
interval 0 1
into 2 pieces i plus and i minus
so that the measure of every mu i on the
two pieces is approximately equal
up to an additive error of epsilon
the crucial point here is that the
partition of the interval
into the two not necessarily connected
pieces
should be made using relatively few cuts
not more than
m the number of given probability
measures and it is known that such a
solution exists even when
epsilon is zero for illustration
consider this density function that
corresponds to mu1
and consider this density function that
corresponds to mu2
as you can see in this case even one cut
suffices to break the interval
into two pieces with the same measure by
mu1
and then u2 the consensus solving
problem was shown by philosophers in
goldberg to be
ppa hard even when epsilon is inverse
polynomial in
m our goal is to transform an instance
of this problem
into an instance of the first splitting
cycle problem
a cycle and the partition of its vertex
set so that given two independent sets
of the cycle that further represent the
partition
and include all vertices but one from
each part of the eye
one can efficiently obtain the cuts of
the interval zero one
that provide the required pieces i plus
and i minus
the reduction has two steps we first
apply a discretization argument that was
previously applied by philosophers in
goldberg to prove the ppa hardness of
the necklace splitting problem
here we associate with the density
function of mu i
a collection vio vertices to do so
we consider the blocks that define this
function
we partition every such block into
blocks of some
fixed small volume and we defined for
each of them
a vertex of vi located in its middle
as you can see in the figure in this
example we partitioned the block of mu1
into four parts of a fixed volume and we
put a red vertex of v1 in each of them
we then partition the blocks of mu2 into
some parts with the same volume and we
put a blue vertex
of v2 in each of them the idea is that
the number of vertices
of v i in every sub interval of 0 1
approximates the measure of mu i in this
interval
after constructing the vertices of every
probability measure
we put all of these vertices in a path
the vertices are ordered in the past
according to the locations on the
interval
so here are the red vertices of v1 and
here are the blue ones of v2
the goal now is to partition the path
using relatively few cuts into two
pieces
each of which contains roughly half of
the vertices of every set of the
partition
in order to relate this problem to
independent sets in
that fairly represent the partition we
need an additional simple trick
done in the second step of the reduction
between every two consecutive vertices
of the path
we add a new dummy vertex and we put all
the new vertices in a new set denoted by
v sub n plus one these are the white
vertices in the figure
finally we simply close this path by
another edge
and get this cycle for correctness we
need to argue
the two disjoining dependent sets in the
obtained cycle
which further represent the partition
and cover almost all of the vertices
can be used to obtain a solution to the
original instance of consensus halving
the idea is that those few vertices that
are
uncovered by the two independent sets
can be viewed as
cuts and every path between two such
cuts
alternates between the two given
independent sets
by the white vertices of the
construction
it means that only one of the two
independent sets contains in such a path
original vertices with colors different
from white
hence every such path can be naturally
assigned
to one of the two presets required by
the consensus solving problem
in fact because of the white vertices we
get from the reduction a partition into
n plus one sets
so the partition of zero one into i plus
and
i minus might involve n plus one cards
instead of
m but luckily the consensus halving
problem is ppa hard
even if we are allowed to use m plus one
cuts
i would like to end the talk with a
couple of open questions
in this world we consider the fair
independent set in cycle problem
in which given a cycle and the partition
of its vertical
the goal is to find an independent set
that further represents the partition
it is shown that this problem is ppa
complete
and it would be interesting to
understand the complexity of this
problem restricted to instances in which
the size of every part of the partition
is bounded from above by some constant
more specifically the special case of
the problem where the vertex that is
partitioned into sets of size 3
is closely related to the search problem
associated with the cycle plus triangles
problem
and it would be interesting to
understand its complexity
another result of this work is the ppa
completeness of describer problem
which given a succinct representation of
a coloring of describe a graph
with fewer colors than its schematic
number asks to find
a monochromatic edge in the graph in
this context
it will be nice to answer a related
question asked by then
fen and kulkarni regarding the
complexity of the analog
problem for knesser graphs the classic
graph
contains the square graph as a sub graph
and it has the same chromatic number
so it will be interesting to figure out
if finding the monochromatic edge in a
knesset graph
given a coloring that uses fewer colors
than its schematic number
is ppa hard as well
thank you for your attention